la mission de ce ministère c'est
d'humaniser le numérique d'abord en
essayant d'obtenir une forme d'autonomie
d'indépendance de maîtrise des
technologies qui demain vont dessiner le
quotidien de nos concitoyens
et ça ça suppose évidemment d'investir
dans l'innovation l'intelligence
artificielle le Cloud le quantique et
nous avons tous les atouts pour réussir
en France et en Europe la deuxième
mission c'est évidemment de garantir à
chacune et à chacun l'accès à l'espace
numérique et ça c'est tout l'enjeu de la
fin du déploiement de la fibre des
réseaux mobiles mais aussi
l'accompagnement humain pour celles et
ceux qui rencontrent des difficultés
pour accéder aux services numériques
on continue à protéger un à un les
établissements de santé les
collectivités les grands établissements
publics pour qu'ils soient armés face à
cette menace qui se généralise et qui
progresse et puis par ailleurs mon
objectif c'est de garantir la
cybersécurité du quotidien à nos
concitoyens et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous travaillons à la mise en
place d'un filtre anti-arnaque qui
viendra sur tous les smartphones sur
tous les ordinateurs prévenir nos
concitoyens lorsque ils s'oriente ou il
se dirige vers un site considéré comme
malveillant
[Musique]
il y a un gros travail qui est mené nous
avons en France des acteurs reconnus
mondialement pour leur savoir-faire en
matière de cybersécurité je pense à Atos
je pense à Thalès et puis à toutes les
startups de la cyber donc je souhaite
qu'elle puisse évidemment jouer un rôle
important dans la protection des sites
et pour éviter ou pour riposter face aux
milliards de tentatives d'intrusion
qu'un manquablement nous allons subir
pendant cette période où l'Île-de-France
et la France seront sous le feu des
projecteurs
je voudrais insister plus
particulièrement sur la protection des
mineurs dans quelques semaines je
présenterai un dispositif de
vérification d'âge fiable
respectueux de la vie privée qui pourra
être utilisé pour une bonne fois pour
toute restreindre l'accès à certains
sites indésirables je pense aussi
pornographiques en particulier à nos
enfants
[Musique]